okay let's go ahead with uh
with another
three-minute game against lady
from austria okay no more
anglo-scandinavian go for
a symmetrical english instead
of all things uh
yeah lots of decent setups here
which one should i choose okay let's go
for
let's go for the modern line
bishop f5 the idea here is um
you want to provoke e4 and then you go
bishop g4
and you're pretty happy with um
the weakness that has been created on on
d4 and otherwise you go for
bishop um like queen d7 and bishop h3
trying to leave yourself with um
uh with the fianchetto bishop against a
non-fiance
bishop um
maybe d5 or bishop xa3 h3 followed by d5
was interesting from there
knight d5 since a bit
a bit soft i don't really know what the
plan was there
um going h5 intending to go h4 possibly
um but als also i just think
um h5
h4 could be a good inclusion for me
now i don't know exactly why it was just
that
my intuition told me that
why intuition why did you tell me that
the intuition doesn't know okay well
will develop normally d5 i think now is
logical um i may go knight a5 then
4xb5 also 95.
either way i'm doing fine but probably
not
more than that if given the chance here
i may take on d4 and then go d5
or actually after p3 now i can go d5
immediately
because of the pin on
um on his rook there was no reason to
to shy away from that 95 is an option
here for him now but i think i'll take
an
e5 then go rook fd8 not really worried
about
the lack of a fiance bishop there um
and uh oh i should be a bit careful
rook d1 8 would be a positional blunder
now because of um
because of the um
yeah because this possibility of
of going for uh for d5 immediately um
now i'm not so worried about d5 though
because i have vision takes b2
followed by by knight f and knight f5
uh rook c1 is a good move once again
preparing d5
in general my opponent is playing very
well here
and very solidly so it's not going to be
easy to win this
okay i'll go
uh which one okay i'll go b6 just to
um prepare knight a5 and um
[Music]
yeah to give it a stable square there
once again i think he should have gotten
d5 there first we need to trade him d2
pull by knight a5 because then he can
jump with the knight to e5 as well
i think in that case he would have been
doing fairly well but
now i think i'm the one who is somewhat
better
and queen a4 is really really annoying
to me because i'm attacking both
a2 and c4
and in case it goes c5 which is the most
logical move in my opinion
then i'll take an a2 and my queen will
find a very nice home on d5
later on consolidating everything
so i think my opponent is basically
losing a pawn here
and this is probably even worse though
because
the thing about when you're playing with
so-called hanging pawns
um which is usually pawns on the
dnc file um nice little tactic here by
the way
uh knight e3 coming up with uh with a
fork and then
rook takes c2 the thing about these
hanging pawns is that
they're very strong together because
they control a lot of squares
but once you lose one of them all of the
squares around
that pawn become very weak so it very
often happens that when you lose one of
the
so-called hanging pawns um
you you're gonna lose both and that is
why
sometimes it's good to have hanging
pawns rather than
an isolated pawn um
because um because you control more
squares
and that is often a choice you get
between hanging pawns and an isolated
pawn
but also um
it means that um
with an isolated pawn you only have
one pawn to lose in the center
and often that can be
uh you can gain some squares from losing
that pawn but
when you lose one of the hanging pawns
often your opponent is the one
who gains uh a lot of squares so it's
always an interesting discussion there